[Music]
[Applause]
he is uh gary klein he covers the rams
for the la times joins us from
cincinnati where the joint practice was
yesterday how would you describe what
happened gary between aaron donald and
the cincinnati bengals
you know dan uh
when these teams get together for joint
practices it always sounds like a great
idea and that first day
everyone's enthusiastic it's great to be
going against an opponent other than
your teammate but when it gets to the
second day frustration sets in and you
know the bengals talked about at least
zach taylor talked about the super bowl
was behind them uh no hard feelings but
i gotta believe you know after two days
of having to go against aaron donald and
the rams going against the bengals
tempers flare and uh you know aaron
donald was in the middle of what was
happening but he was not the only one
there was uh punches thrown people
kicking people shoving uh it fortunately
at least as far as i know no one was
hurt uh but there were helmets swinging
and uh it was quite a scene that led to
the end of practice any indication if
the rams will take any disciplinary
action against aaron donald
no i i would be stunned if the rams uh
any kind of disciplinary thing sean
mcvay talks about you know
you need to protect teammates you need
to you know you need to stand up for
yourself um they are not going to find a
player that they just gave a massive
extension to that's a leader of their
team
[Music]
in some way
you know i'm sure mcvay
came away from that with a little bit of
i don't want to say pride but i'm sure
he walked away with my guys stood up for
each other and even though his attitude
is nothing to see here we've forgotten
about it in 30 seconds i'd be like i
said i'd be stunned if anything happened
to aaron donald
i know the nfl has told us this morning
it's up to the
teams
does the nf okay what's the difference
between aaron donald swinging helmets
and miles garrett doing something on
national tv during the regular season
well that i think that's a valid
argument and and today you know in
today's media
uh atmosphere where things are on video
and they're distributed all over the
world uh you could make that case but
that is the nfl's policy that what
happened in practice uh is under the
purview of the teams and that's why i'm
saying i if this was something the nfl
was going to get involved in i don't
think there's any question there would
be some kind of
some kind of fine or discipline but
because it's teams involved
i don't think it's going to happen if
you're gonna handicap this rams team
this year
the reason why they'll repeat is what
and the reason why they won't is one
well i think the reason if they do
repeat which we all know is very very
very difficult this doesn't happen uh
they have upgraded in a couple positions
and i think the addition of bobby wagner
on the defense gives them all pros at
every level with aaron donald bobby
wagner and jalen ramsey leading that
defense and then even though that odell
beckham jr you know is still a free
agent they traded uh robert woods allen
robinson the addition of him uh to go
along with cooper cup uh i think makes
them stronger in a lot of ways on
offense but
dan for
from what i see the most difficult thing
the reason they may not is just because
it is such a long season you have to be
good you have to be lucky the breaks
have to go your way and also i think
your players have to be so motivated
over that 17 game season and the
playoffs to actually complete that run i
just think there's a reason why teams
fatigue or people get injured and it
just doesn't work out
um
you know it's it's an interesting team
you got big personalities there then you
have the matt stafford situation at
least it felt like it was front burner
now
where do we stand with stafford's elbow
and health status going into the season
long term
well i think in the short term he's
going to be fine you know mcveigh of
course caused a firestorm when he said
it was abnormal you know for a
quarterback and that he was feeling pain
more like a baseball injury
so stafford has played he's going into
his 14th season he's got things you know
parts of his body that i'm sure ache all
the time and i think his right arm is is
is going to be a project through the
season they're going to have to manage
it at this point you know over the last
two days he looks as good as ever you
know he's firing passes all over the
place but they haven't started hitting
him yet he hasn't had his arm yanked by
j.j watt or anyone else yet so i think
through something they're gonna have to
manage uh the way they did it this
offseason was to have him not throw that
seems to at least have put him in a
position to be effective you know at the
start of the season but i think it's an
ongoing thing that he's gonna have to
manage the rest of his career yeah sean
mcvay made this more of a story so he
can't be you guys are making you know a
big deal of no you made a big deal we
would have said oh you know maybe
tenderness in his elbow the rams more
likely to repeat or miss the playoffs in
your opinion oh i think they'll they'll
make the playoffs i i don't know that i
would go so far as to say they're going
to repeat but the nfc west
i think is not as strong as it was last
year you know the seahawks don't have a
quarterback uh the cardinals situation
is kind of interesting and they haven't
proven they can go the long haul the
49ers will be good because just they are
they'll be tough but i think the rams
will make the playoffs but they got some
breaks last season not having to go to
green bay uh you know a miracle great
play against the buccaneers and you know
coming back against the bengals so they
did everything they had to do last year
but again you got to go back to 2004 to
find a team that was able to repeat it's
just not that easy in the nfl play nice
there in cincinnati gary okay
will do damn thanks very much yeah don't
take on a cincinnati reporter you know i
just you know
neutral corners there thank you gary
thank you that's uh gary klein he's
joining us from cincinnati
now he thinks no punishment
which
look i'm not calling for it
i'm just speculating that
is there going to be would there be
should there be if the nfl was going to
govern this
then
i have to believe the nfl would punish
aaron donald because of the public
reaction to this
that's what the nfl bases it feels like
their punishment on sometimes